Love.
Yeah, I might… oh, oh, oh.
I…
Nice.
Hello, Bali?
That's the case, because I have access in the database controller.
Uh,
Listen.
my… where I…
Rahal Alimen?
Are they?
They lasted better, hey.
It is not…
Jose?
front end.
Where…
You won't have a developer client.
I…
might just say,
Hey, is I'm Mahana?
Oh.
Meh.
Vanokana.
God.
Yes, sir.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm running a little, uh, register for you.
Did they?
uh… what's…
And then,
Job ID.
So, the entire…
management.
amend me?
Meeting Badi.
Meeting, uh, meeting the badin.
Mish.
Uh, legend.
So, Izin, as in visual.
However, our size of an expected output action.
is in visual.
Right.
Uh… oh.
They cannot comment loser.
Hey, I recommend.
Mafish.
Where, with online description must boot,
Oh.
machineset.
information.
Linac and Andakum and Smarshitag ground aizabetho.
Wow.
Yeah, I…
Russia.
me.
Let me see.
Is that the same?
Mesh.
el lugo,
Samosby?
La
Oh, miss.
must move, must move.
Mesh.
Mike, I…
Enta, bus.
Why is that hidden
I will el…
Right.
Limit that… selectamente.
Okay.
Well,
team planning.
In video, ziktir.
You don't know how the residential leis.
Thermosley?
I mean…
inshaAllah.
Vatican is.
I'll… .
But I was a…
Betuli.
Ali.
a Zoom meeting, a Google meeting.
kit.
The new OE's entire day.
All of that did then over my shit, then.
That can be kind of mindful public, uh…
Okay.
Both
Mish
Nice.
Hello, yes, alright
Neither.
And also,
Some of them…
phenomenal.
Someone in my placement spill.
Close. Okay
Hello, Commissioner Anne.
Mish.
Yeah,
mass… masses of it.
Yep.
Awesome.